new monuments are now on display not too
far from downtown city leaders adding
them as a way to honor historic las
vegas historic west side community you
can find them
on the on and off ramps at u.s 95 at mlk
8 news now reporter madison kimbrough
live tonight with an up close
and personal look madison
yes brian take a look at this monument
sign it is very visible right as you get
off of 95.
local artist harold bradford says he
wanted to create a sense of community
with this piece back in the day the
historic west side of las vegas
was home to mostly african americans and
their businesses
the rich culture that took place on the
west side has never been forgotten
and now with these signs in present day
this is just one way the city hopes to
revitalize the area
well as a person that grew up in the
historic west side and still lives in
historic wayside
there's a sense of pride that we all
have there's some something
within that design that they they
perhaps feel that they can hold on to
and that was my concern also and i had
you know all that in mind as
as i started my designs
and the sign on the north side of the
u.s 95 off-ramp is not completely
finished yet
but will have a four foot wide walking
path allowing people to come
up and take pictures now if you look
really closely you'll notice that the
design
is in the shape of a compass and that
star you see
that is supposed to represent the west
side it is a beautiful
monument that we see right here great
way to represent
this historic area reporting live
madison kimbrough
8 news now